alors ça me je ne peux pas pas d'un
jeune adorable petit garçon de 10 ans
prénommé julian julian il est là ce soir
on va faire une interview dis donc papa
c'est julian qui parle mais on papa
c'est quoi ton métier en ce moment je
suis acteur monfils débrouille a pas de
film de toiles affichant senti mon fils
si on vient de faire un film qui
s'appelle indigènes âgés n'y avait
absolument et il ya des propositions
mais tout ce qu'on a proposé jusqu'à
maintenant c'est des choses que j'avais
pas envie de faire donc plutôt de
prendre de l'argent et faire n'importe
quoi je préfère attendre ta pas assez
dur d'être acteur oui
ils n'ont pas pas pourquoi tu as plus
droit de conduire de voiture parce que
j'ai déconné mon fils et il faut pas que
tu fasses comme moi justement dit donc
pas passer c'est dangereux les hôtesses
de l'air
non c'est gentil mais il faut être
gentil avec elle 1 puis quand tu parles
bien côté policand
quand tu prends le bon avion ça se passe
bien mais pas inquiet mais une qui était
attaqué un jour être toi tu ne cherches
toi je suis ton fils en même temps j'ai
donc papa faut obéir à la police où il
faut baieriverain police tu leur pays
toi papa oui
dit non on peut battre j'avais des
problèmes avec les policiers toi
non mon fils jamais tu travaillais bien
l'école non et moi papa il faut que tu
travailles bien l'école louis à tout
seul premier de la classe pour pas
rentrer dans la police
et donc 20 ans il ya quoi comme métier
quand on veut être riche et rien [ __ ]
paris 16 tonnes c'est bien ouais acteurs
c'est bien tu peux frapper des flics et
puis touchez une enveloppe à la fin du
film assez sympa
bien on papa je dois te fumer à quel âge
tu fume pas mon fils tu fais du sport tu
fais de la boxe thaï avec mon papa tu
vas mourir un jour oui comme quoi je
sais pas mais je serai toujours là pour
te surveiller et tu vas avoir un césar
un jour papa je sais pas si dieu veut
ouais il va comment tonton bibi il va
très bien et sorti
la semaine dernière d'ailleurs il
cherche
non pas tant ils sont onze entités
copain lui il est super gentil un
super-héros grigolo c'est une crème mais
je ne voudrais jamais me bagarre avec le
film fait peur un peu à moi mais pas
violent nouveau tram en pleine noirceur
didon papa tu promets qu'ils ratent
jamais en prison non tu aimerais que te
ressemble papa
quelque part oui
tu as peur de quoi pour moi papa
j'ai peur qu il devienne un gangster
ils ont pas battus peuvent avoir une
autographes jamel debbouze ça y'a pas de
problème mon fils dit papa on t'a traité
de sale arabe toi aussi oui mon fils
qu'est ce t'as fait j'ai mis une droite
dans la gueule
pourquoi il ya des gens qui disent que
tu as pété un plomb tu es devenu
électricien ou quoi
non j'ai pas devenu électricien jugé
papeete de plomb j'ai comme je vais je
vais je vais pas citer de noms mais il y
en a un paquet il ya un paquet d'acteurs
qui à un moment donné ça te monte à la
tête et puis tu crois sur une autre
sphère tu dis ça y est je suis acteur
c'est arrivé c'est bon et puis tu es sur
une bulle tu es là oh et puis tu te
crois voilà quoi papa je peux te prendre
comme modèle
pas sur tous les points de vue t'as pas
un peu grossi papa si j'ai grossi mais
là je vais maigrir parce qu'ils vont
découvrir avec eux c'est quoi ce qui est
le plus important dans la vie papa
l'amour
et ses qui dieu dieu c'est lui qui te
regarde et à chaque fois que tu en fais
une qui est pas bien il vient y ait un
bon coup de matraque derrière la tête
pour pas que tu recommences à celle de
radès
de reprendre un toit dis donc papa tu
veux quoi pour la fête des pères
je veux que tu sois le plus fort à
l'école d'accord
on fait quoi demain papa dimanche mounir
au skatepark monfils merci papa et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous il m'était impossible
ou